ich habe Verwandte verloren in diesem
Krieg und ich habe verstanden das Leben
wird nie wieder sein wie es einmal war
das Schwarze Meer Odessa Heimat für
Katharina Odessa ist der Ort an den sie
eigentlich gehört doch wegen des
russischen Angriffskrieges ist Katharina
seit 11 Monaten in Deutschland hier ist
sie sicher aber seelisch geht es ihr
nicht gut
das größte Problem ist der Verlust und
die Trauer du siehst deine Zukunft du
siehst dein Leben alles ist gut und dann
von einer Sekunde auf die andere
zerbricht dein ganzes Leben alles ändert
sich und du musst überleben ich glaube
ich bin fünf bis zehn Jahre gealtert
wegen all dieser Emotionen
katharina ist 26 Jahre alt studiert an
der Kunsthochschule in Berlin durch ihre
Bilder sagt sie versucht sie Ausdruck
für ihren Schmerz zu finden der
Herzschlag aus dem Takt
wenn man etwas verloren hat kann man
richtig schätzen was man hatte
family heute weiß ich ich war so
beschenkt mit meiner Familie mit meinen
Freunden
und auch wenn es natürlich manchmal
Probleme gab ich bin so glücklich in
diesem Land aufgewachsen zu sein
Hilfe findet Katharina in der
psychologischen Hochschule Berlin
Therapeutinnen in Ausbildung beraten
hier geflüchtete was alle eint sei die
fluchterfahrung sagt Therapeutin Tanja
Trost Menschen denen der sichere
bodenfehler auf dem man sich sonst
bewegt
viele
haben Selbstmordgedanken oder den
Gedanken ihr Leben zu beenden und das
ist natürlich eine Verzweiflung die sich
gegen sich selbst richtet oft sind ja
die sozialen Systeme sehr
auseinandergerissen
teilweise sind Familienangehörige noch
zu Hause geblieben oder in andere Länder
geflüchtet die Freunde sind in aller
Welt zerstreut also dieses ganze soziale
System ist zerrissen die Beratung ist
unbürokratisch und schnell das ist was
Sie tun können sie helfen ehrenamtlich
der Bedarf ist riesig es gibt in der
psychotherapeutischen Versorgung eine
große Lücke das betrifft eigentlich alle
Abschnitte der Versorgungskette und das
betrifft natürlich die gesamte
Bevölkerung aber insbesondere diese
Population der geflüchteten weil wir da
einfach noch mehr Barrieren haben die
wir sonst auch schon in der Aufnahme von
psychologischer Behandlung haben
das Projekt steps geht auch in Schulen
die Grundschule am Brandenburger Tor hat
fast 20 Kinder aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen die Kinder leiden unter
Konzentrationsstörung können nicht
schlafen haben Ängste werden gewalttätig
immer und immer wieder durchleben manche
ihre Traumata
ändert sich im Leben es ist schlimm dass
wir gezwungen wurden umzuziehen seither
ist alles ein bisschen
meine Katze ist in der Ukraine geblieben
mit Papa das kostet mich so viel Kraft
und als es losging mit dem Krieg daran
denke ich oft es war 2 Uhr nachts da
sagten meine Eltern Lisa packt dein Zeug
steh auf wir müssen weg
beim wöchentlichen ukrainski Club dem
ukrainischen Club können die
kindergemeinschaft Erleben von ihren
Gefühlen erzählen
[Musik]
der Krieg und das so vieles nicht mehr
möglich ist macht mich traurig und meine
Mutter sie weint immer zu
ganz oft möchte ich einfach meinen
Koffer packen aber ich darf nicht
verständlich na klar obwohl ich mich oft
ärgere dass ich mit meinen Eltern
mitgegangen bin damals dieser 24 Februar
2022 kauft mir echt Energie
die Väter die noch in der Ukraine sind
zurückgelassene Großeltern oder auch die
Sehnsucht nach dem Haustier macht manche
Kinder krank vor Kummer nicht so gut
darum geht es dir nicht gut mir gefällt
es besser in der Ukraine ich weiß ja
dass es hier eigentlich schöner ist aber
da ist doch meine Heimat
sprechen zuhören Gefühle sehen und
zulassen das versuchen die Therapeutin
von steps und die Schulsozialarbeiterin
hier wir merken schon stark dass das die
Kinder
dass die Kinder hier die Möglichkeit
haben ihre Emotionen zu benennen und
auch mal zu gucken wie fühlt sich Wut
überhaupt an wie fühlt sich Trauer an
und ja das tut den sehr gut uns ist
aufgefallen dass die Kinder oft einfach
so Flashbacks natürlich erleben ja auch
sowas wie jetzt klingelt es ist für
viele Kinder eine Tür wird zugeschlagen
da erschrecke ich mich drüber und oft
sind die danach einfach gar nicht mehr
wieder zurückzuholen in den Unterricht
ihre Kindheit überwältigt vom
ungeheuerlichen und doch sind sie voller
Hoffnung
was wünscht du dir hier was wünscht du
dir ich wünsche mir Glück
ein
leben
weil ich wollte das dann Wunsch für alle
königliche Menschen Glück ein gutes
Leben und Frieden und dass das Leben
wieder Ruhe findet das wünschen sich die
Kinder nach einem Jahr Krieg in der
Ukraine